- [Narrator] Meet Jenny Lee.
- [Jenny] My name is Jenny, and
I lobbied for the dumpling,
take-out box, fortune cookie,
and chopsticks emojis.
- [Narrator] And this is
the story of how Jenny
is getting up four new emoji.
- [Jenny] Like it just felt
to me that there should be
a dumpling emoji.
And like, while we're at it,
we should add the take-out
box, fortune cookie,
and chopsticks.
As of 2017, they are coming
to a keyboard near you.
- [Narrator] Jenny was
on an emoji crusade.
You see, in order to pitch an emoji,
you have to infiltrate
this world-wide consortium
named Unicode.
- [Jenny] You get very quickly
to the Unicode consortium
which is a non-profit organization
which basically oversees emoji.
- [Narrator] They're
the people who control
the alphabet of your emoji keyboard.
- [Jenny] It has 11 full voting members.
They pay $18,000 a year
to like have a full vote.
(siren blaring)
- [Narrator] Unicode sets
the standard in parameters
around emoji.
You see, there are a set of
rules all emoji must abide by.
- [Jenny] There are no brands,
no deities, and no celebrities.
And when we hear about quote Kimoji
those are not real accepted emoji.
Those are sort of rogue emoji
that are really stickers.
- [Narrator] So Jenny
started to attend meetings.
For a swift $75, anyone
can attend the meeting
as a non-voting member.
- [Jenny] And you basically
like feel very welcome
and so it feels a lot like
going to a new church.
(Church chorale singing)
- [Narrator] Back to the dumpling.
- [Jenny] What I did was
write a whole proposal
about why the dumpling
deserved it's own emoji
especially since it's so universal.
And what's kind of cool is that not only
is it a dumpling emoji,
it can be a pierogi emoji,
or an empanada emoji.
Got that passed as a candidate emoji
in January of this year.
- [Narrator] Seems like a
lot of work for fun symbols.
- [Jenny] No, it was actually much faster
than I thought.
- [Narrator] Oh, okay.
- [Jenny] I think it's really interesting
to watch the emoji evolve.
- [Narrator] And that my friends
is how an emoji is born.
(upbeat music)